I woke up in Munich around 8 a.m.
feeling pretty jet-lagged
even by yawns up yawns then I went down
to the s-bahn where I was reminded that
without warning death rays from space
might throw me onto the track
nonetheless I managed to make it to the
airport and then caught a plane to
Vienna where in the safety card
explicitly mentioned two things I could
not use on the plane my phone and my
remote-control car then we landed in
Vienna which is locked in a fierce
competition with Munich for world's
greatest sky I took a cab to my hotel
room and then set out to explore the
city I'd never been to the end of before
but it's a great city for new visitors
because it's very dense and there are
these huge streets that are for
pedestrians only the first thing I
noticed is that Vienna is packed with
babies baby baby baby baby rotating
Mozart head baby baby ah babies they
made me miss Henry don't tell me they're
cherubs they're not cherubs they're
baby's adorable dancing babies
most pigeons are distressingly close to
me immediately thereafter a pigeon
crapped on my coat and because I am
smart I wiped it off with my hand then I
kept walking I saw a goethe and a
two-headed eagle and narcissistic
graffiti and this building which
happened to feature the world's most
awesome
bird on the king of the birds I'm a fly
way now then I went to a park and saw
Mozart and more babies and space
invaders opposed to homophobia and do
not tread on the green pressure patter
you will be shot with a laser in your
head will come off also no dogs allowed
sexy poses on the other hand are
encouraged I walked for a while longer
until I reached the albertina museum
where William Kentridge one of my
favorite artists was on exhibit well he
wasn't on exhibit but his artwork was
Hank the camera show was so good that I
took out my camcorder to show some of it
to you whereupon my camcorder was
immediately confiscated by security the
next 40 minutes of my footage is just
this I don't know what that guy's doing
with my camcorder but it seems unholy
well the important thing is that I got
my camera back then I walked over to st.
Stephen's Cathedral because I'd heard
you could tour the catacombs and I love
me some catacombs you weren't allowed to
film down there either but I did get
some footage of these urns which
contained a pickled innards of various
hapsburgs including Franz Josef the
first shown here whose beard clippings
sadly were not preserved but while I
can't show you much of what I saw down
in the catacombs I can show you what was
happening that day directly above them
inside the church people lit candles and
took pictures outside in the square a
balloon man waited for customers while a
huge crowd of people surrounded a b-boy
dance crew there are more than 11,000
people buried beneath this square and
when the catacombs got full prisoners
were sent down to stack the bones of the
decomposed in order to free up more
space I got a little footage of one such
bone room for 400 years Vienna buried
its dead down here but they quit in 1783
because the stench of decomposition had
become so overwhelming that people no
longer wanted to go to church hearing
that made me think about all the ways
that the dead haunt us and it made me
wonder how do we best honor the dead by
placing them close to our sacred spaces
by marveling at the extraordinary places
they've made for us that's not a
rhetorical question by the way as I
walked away
around Vienna that night I kept
wondering what if anything do we owe the
dead Hank I'll see you tomorrow